all right so protesters
took to these steps at the capitol
yesterday to call for uh legislation
protecting voting rights let's just play
a little bit of this footage here
you can see the the um
let's see them and they're
they're singing
a little gospel him here
oh look is that a pastor with a rainbow
shaw or whatever that is
[Applause]
not going to let no filibuster turn me
around they're singing
and i'm informed by twitter that they
also
are they're on a hunger strike
which it looks like for a few of them
that might actually benefit them so it
isn't a bad idea
you got them singing and chanting for
voting rights meanwhile
they they have it they have all the
voting rights in the world
every single person there
protesting going on a hunger strike for
voting rights
they all have it someone just needs to
walk down those steps and say hey guys
uh good news you can all vote
wow does that mean that the voting
rights law was passed no no you've had
this right literally your whole life so
just go
you're fine go
this is how desperate people are
to
tell themselves that they're in some
sort of struggle
that they're suffering when they're not
really
desperate to be victims of course
desperate to be oppressed
uh whoopi goldberg over at the view she
says that um
that as bad as it is now with voting
rights and no one can explain what the
problem is or how anyone's being
prevented from voting she says that um
this this current phantom attack on
voting rights will only lead to even
scarier phantoms in the future
listen to this
this is part of the big plan this is
part of the big plan to control what
happens in america i believe what
happens in america
you take those voting rights away people
are going to be so angry but there'll be
nothing they can do about because we're
in charge next thing comes the women
we're going to take your rights away
just like we're taking x y and z because
there'll be nothing you can do this
country
seemingly or many people in it seemingly
want to be
manipulated oh i was going to say to
destroy it well i don't know if they
realize that it will be destructive
because listen when we talk about
anti-semitism and we talk about anne
frank and we can't teach what happens to
black people and which we you know
there's all kinds of stuff that's
suddenly starting to disappear now
that isn't it that is being sort of
called as well yeah it's just you
whining that's just you saying this is
happening to me
you gotta take away the women's voting
rights
that's what she thinks as i said i mean
there's there's
i have not advocated for taking women's
voting rights away
i haven't heard anyone advocate for that
seriously
um
as you know i am in favor of removing
voting rights from lots of people
and probably everybody on the view
but not specifically based on gender or
race just based on um how how stupid
they are and that's why you know
certainly the the bar that we would set
even if it was a fifth grade civics exam
that would exclude everybody on the view
but you know then again since she raised
the point i mean i'm not the one who
brought this up but she brought it up
about taking voting rights away from
women again i
i'm not in favor of that
but when i watch the view for even a
moment
you do start to think maybe there's an
argument like the best argument for
taking bunny rights away from women is
is actually the view so that's kind of
the irony here
but that's that's not what it's about
and as you know i'm i'm the only i'm a
voice in the wilderness crying out
nobody else is talking about removing
voting rights from anybody
that is just not that's that's
not a thing that's happening
but this is what the democrats are
focused on that's what joe biden is
focused on
joe biden who has
uh just completed
what what i think we can say without
exaggeration is the worst first year of
any president
in american history
and his approval ratings are plummeting
now they're at at last i saw was it 32
or 33
and this is what
people in this country are facing a lot
of practical problems
in their in their lives real problems
inflation is a real problem
the price of milk and bread these are
real problems that affect your everyday
life price of gasoline is a real problem
um
but democrats are all fighting mythical
dragons
slaying the monster that wants to take
voting rights away totally imaginary
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content